este sábado el Papa Francisco se dirigió
a los desplazados internos de Sudán del
sur con un mensaje de apoyo y de
Consuelo a estas millones de personas
que se han visto obligadas a abandonar
sus pueblos a causa de la violencia el
papa les mostró su cercanía su cariño
estoy con ustedes sufro por ustedes y
con ustedes dijo el papa según las
Naciones Unidas desde 2013 4 millones y
medio de personas se han visto obligadas
a huir en este país entre ellas más de
dos millones han encontrado refugio en
países vecinos el resto se ha desplazado
dentro del país se trata de la crisis de
refugiados más grave del continente
africano Francisco de cloro el destino
de niños y jóvenes que crecen en campos
de desplazados e hizo un llamado para
poner fin al sufrimiento del pueblo de
Sudán del sur reactivando seriamente el
proceso de Paz en este país martirizado
por la guerra y la violencia